après de longues semaines d'arrêt
provoqué par l'épidémie du coronavirus
est la campagne des municipales reprend
le second tour aura bien lieu le 28 juin
prochain pour ce scrutin inédit
plusieurs enjeux sont à prendre en
considération dans quelques grandes
villes car les alliances pourrait tout
faire basculer
prenons le rassemblement national à
perpignan louis aliot ancrée depuis près
de 12 ans dans cette file fait office de
favori face à son score de 35,6 % au
premier tour les candidats
lrm et europe ecologie les verts qui se
sont à désister ou appeler à lui faire
barrage sans pour autant appeler à voter
pour le candidat ait l'air et maire
sortant jean marc pujol toujours en lice
avec 18,4 pour cent mais les alliances
multiplient dans les autres villes à
strasbourg et les écologistes feront
face à l'alliance l air l hérault m
europe ecologie les verts peut espérer
l'emporter dans la capitale du grand
test ou sa candidate
jeanne bars et gyan est arrivé en tête
au premier tour avec près de 28% des
voix
ce résultat a fait naître une alliance
inédite entre la droite et les marcheurs
le maintien de la candidature socialiste
faute d'accord rend moins probable une
victoire des écologistes et donc pas
d'alliance à venir à paris emmanuel
macron et ses troupes avaient réalisé de
très bons scores en 2017 et 2019
mais cette année le moral est en berne
la candidate lrm agnès buzyn n'a
engrangé que 17,3 pour cent des voix le
15 mars
loin derrière la socialiste anne hidalgo
avec 29,3 pour cent et là elle est
rachida dati avec à 22,7 pour cent
l'entre-deux-tours a tourné au vinaigre
pour les marcheurs notamment après des
propos explosifs de l'ancien ministre de
la santé tenue au quotidien le monde sur
la gestion de l'épidémie de covile 19
est la candidate lrm se maintient
finalement pour le second tour sans
alliance et ses vues lâché par sa
candidate dans le 5e arrondissement de
paris et qui a annoncé soutenir rachida
dati à saint-denis également en ile de
france
elle est divisée
on menace les communistes c'est le
socialiste matthieu annotant qui a pris
l'avantagé 15 mars dernier avec 35,3 %
des votes et coups de théâtre
le maire sortant pcf lors en russie est
créditée de 24% des voix n'a pas réussi
à s'entendre avec l'insoumis à bali
bagayoko crédité de 18%
et même si ce dernier ancien membre de
la majorité a retiré sa candidature
la tension entre les deux camps restent
fortes l évolution du taux d'abstention
de près de 70% au premier tour pourrait
tout faire basculer à landecy le maire
sortant laurent hénart du mouvement
radical avec 34,7 % des voix s'est vu
devancé au premier tour par les 37,8
pour cent du socialiste mathieu klein
président du département
ce dernier pourrait profiter de la
fusion de sa liste avec celle de
l'écologiste laurent ou à train une
victoire peut être en vue pour un ps
divisé et qui peine à remonter la pente
depuis la débâcle de 2017 une campagne
pas comme les autres pour les candidats
qui ne pourront pas faire de porte à
porte avec l'épidémie de coronavirus
l'abstention pourrait atteindre un taux
record le premier tour du scrutin avait
déjà été marqué par une abstention
massive à 55%
elle soit près de 20 points de plus que
les 30 6,5 pour cent du premier tour des
municipales de 2014